joining us right now is one of my
favorite people on the planet and i just
said you know what
i want to talk to this man i want to
hear what he's got to say i want to talk
about the las vegas raiders i want to
talk football college and pro and just
see what is going on
with a hall of famer and hall of fame
broadcaster
and uh the managing editor vision on his
boys in the desert
he is none other than brent mossberger
how are you brent
hey i am great rich uh what a what a
month
just listen to you run down the things
that are going on obviously
because of the pandemic we've never had
in october like this to remember but
uh you know last night you know rich
obviously i watched every snap because
the raiders
the raiders play the jets on the road
and they've got the two games against
denver and the
afc westin and i'm listening to a lot of
people uh
ah two terrible team blah blah that was
an a-plus entertainment show last year
i mean listen mistakes okay
we got it i have to tell you a funny
little betting story because uh
i i had a position on the under
going into the game and i thought i'm in
trouble and i thought early
so i took i i took the broncos in the
second half
and um brett ripland my favorite uh
quarterback most recently out of boise
state
checks up that pick six and i'm thinking
this may wind up being a bad night but
then
how about that lead bridge have you ever
seen a quarterback get out in front
of a running back like ripon did and
and actually he impeded the final
defensive player who had a chance to
take gordon down
i thoroughly i thoroughly enjoyed the
game
yeah brent
so are you saying you were overjoyed is
that what you're saying i was
overjoyed
[Laughter]
that's right national treasure brent
mussberger here on the rich eisen show
you've got a great game coming up on
sunday in front of you
man i love this game bills raiders
and there's going to be a ton of
talented players on the field
i give you the floor on how you think
this might play out with the 3-0 bills
and josh allen bringing his mvp
uh first three weeks of play into into
vegas sir
yeah you know josh uh josh as you know
has been
has been spectacular the afc
player of the month and the third i
think was third down and
21 against the rams when he was trying
to bring him from behind
and the rams put the shutdown corner
over on the best receiver so we found
beasley
and hit him for the first down kept
going then got the win and
the raider defense was not at its best
against the new england patriots to say
the least bill belichick with a power
running game ran all
over them the raiders will have their
hands full i got to tell you a funny
story though because
the monday night game that people
watched and the raiders
upset the new orleans saints was the
weirdest
the weirdest situation i've ever found
myself in because
we're call i'm calling the road games
remotely i want to point that out
from from our radio boosting allegiance
and uh having a two billion dollar
stadium all to myself for a couple of
years
along with animals lincoln kennedy and
they cater us at halftime
just hasn't been a bad deal you know as
long as you're gonna socially distance
give me a two billion dollar brand new
state anyway
yes so the same thing the town now i
really miss the crowd i'm looking down
at the field okay
now you know when you're watching at
home as we were last night
the crowd noise is pumped in by uh the
fox broadcast crew is doing it on the
nfl network
and and so you get that little
background noise i don't get that
in my headset so i'm getting chatter
down on the side i have to tell you
i love mr jagger he's one of my favorite
guys in the nf
i didn't know they officiated every play
in the nfl you know what i mean
yeah i heard that chatter down there i
mean he was helping him all out okay
well it was a first
down a bad mark bad spot that's got to
be interference that's not
and it kind of threw me off my game i
hadn't heard that chatter quite like
that
before but it'll be it'll be all hands
on deck
for this game against the bills uh
the you know the bills will come in here
a sl a slight favorite
uh the public in las vegas loves to back
the home team as they did the vegas goal
tonight so do it with the uh
with the right but there's an injury
situation uh which we should point out
will really impact the raiders
uh this week they're going to be without
edwards and rux
to their two fine rookie wide receivers
and and i doubt
that aguilar and renfro
and zay jones who used to be a bill i
doubt that that puts fear in the heart
of the secondary of the uh
the buffalo bill so so the raiders
obviously
will will have to keep josh allen off
the field
that means a steady diet of josh jacobs
and there again the raiders have got
injury problems
that we've got a rookie at left guard
and we're still fine to
get trump brown back onto the field over
there at the right tackle spot
now having said that john groot is
extremely creative he's got
waller and monroe and witten as his
tight ends and occasionally he'll sneak
in carrier
and he's one of the most creative
coaches i've ever been around when it
comes
to using two and three tight ends and
then having rub plays and
even use waller even winds up because
waller is
maybe the fastest tight in the nfl i
want to be careful because i don't know
the speed of all of them
but he certainly is in our in our
division uh
not not as powerful as kelsey over there
in kansas city
but waller can flat-out move and uh so
the raiders will go
to a multiplicity of looks uh bill
belichick oh my goodness belichick
unbelievable unbelievable what he did he
took walnut away
he's famous for taking away what you do
best that he took walter away
uh last sunday and now belichick and
the patriots go play those kansas city
chiefs
interesting uh the patriots are catching
seven points here in vegas rich
belichick was hired back in 2000 the
patriots have been an underdog seven or
more times under belichick 11 different
times 11 different times
seven or more dog nine and two ats
so beware mr belichick i know kansas
city
impressed everybody everybody with that
great performance at baltimore
but mr belichick can be lethal in
situations like that
and so we shall see the great brent
musburger here
on the rich eisen show and you you know
given us the breakdown on the on the
raiders and
and uh and the bills and then the
patriots and the chiefs that's dynamite
uh i do want to give you the floor
though
on the conversation that has been um
you know nationally discussed and uh
or or is is as discussed to the disgust
of uh new orleans you've seen a lot of
football brent what did you see with
drew brees that night on monday night
football did you see a guy didn't want
to go down the field couldn't go down
the field or just decided to take what
he would
he would get to try and beat the team
that was in front of him what do you
make of that
conversation uh you know i followed drew
brees um
i did a lot of his games at purdue uh
just
just a terrific a terrific person i
think that uh
the charitable contributions that he and
his wife have done
i was never around a university where
someone gave back
i was rookie contract quite like drew
brees did what purdue so i stand
second to nobody in my uh my admiration
for drew
but at the age of 41 there has been and
what i think is deterioration
in the arm strength which is nobody
beats father time we all understand that
cliche
he was without michael thomas in all
fairness who is his best
his best deep receiver and hopefully the
saints will have him back back down this
week now they were down two touchdowns
in the second half
and i can't remember how many plays but
it looked like drew brees took him down
the field
in a matter of minutes the the
misunderstanding about
check down by analysts except those
coaches who are there
if you hit a receiver in flight and he's
got
daylight in front of him he can take a
seven yard check down
into a 22-23 yard gain okay
they did not do that okay they they drew
was off just a little bit on a couple of
his throws
i know one time i even commented on the
edit he was running a sideline route and
he threw way away from his receiver he
was definitely
definitely off his game
and and we shall see because i i i do
want to point out to everybody
you know we used to call reggie jackson
okay uh
mr october all right well i will tell
you right now
beware the new orleans saints in the
month of october
the saints have covered their last 17
straight october games
dating back to 2015 and oh by the way
they're 16-1 straight up during that
period in the month of october
so mr october that's the entire team
down there
in new orleans but rich to answer your
question there is no doubt
as he goes older uh the arm is not quite
like it used to be
and that is certainly understandable if
you look at tom brady
brady through the years with the
patriots under josh mcdaniel and
coach belichick that crossing guy
whether it was gronkowski or edelman
where he only had to throw the ball
about 10 yards
but he hit those receivers in flight
okay and they took off from there
so so we shall see i thought the saints
honestly i didn't approve of the play
calling
by the coach you know you know i'm a
second guesser like everybody else
i thought they were a little bit all
over the place against the raiders
and i didn't understand why he suddenly
took an extra point off the board and
decided to go for two and then another
penalty that was taken off
i thought that pissed the raiders off uh
when they did that took about five
minutes for that whole scene to unfold i
i didn't think coach was at his best
over on the same sideline in that game
uh so so so let's see what happens uh
they go to detroit
they go to detroit and give a little bit
over the field goal
lions coming off very impressive win
last week so so we'll see what happens
with the saints
who was your uh preseason prediction for
the super bowl how's that holding up
three plus weeks well i took the afc
they were
minus two and a half and i thought okay
i've got the chief but i've also got the
ravens in my hip pocket and i thought
those were the two most powerful teams
uh in football coming in so i'm sitting
with that i
i did check it yesterday and the afc is
now a four-point favorite
uh to win the super bowl so so we will
see i think that the
nfc is a jump ball obviously the green
bay packers
have been very very impressive but i
noticed a story breaking late last night
i want to check at the lazard
i could be out here i thought that he
and rogers were
forming a good compliment when they
didn't have adams out on the field i
still
i i don't understand what the packers
were thinking of in the first round of
the draft
there were so many quality receivers out
there i know i i just i said
what are you thinking of i mean you're
not the future i mean
don't even think about that roger's not
going anywhere for a few years so i
i thought they botched the draft um
going forward and now we'll see if they
get a little short-handed they've got to
have devante adams back
but the falcons you know they just can't
get out of their way i who
who can figure the way they've blown the
last couple can i want to say one thing
about that onside kick
yeah one of the things that some of the
people have overlooked
that kick that was spinning was toward
the dallas sideline now you and i
both know there were at least at least
three players over the l.a don't touch
it don't touch it has to go 10 yards has
to go 10.
you could have never pulled that onside
kick off if you had gone toward the
falcon sideline i
i thought it was one of the most
creative plays that i've seen in a long
time of course coach fossil young
apostle
who was with the rams did a great job
over there he brought zerline
with him to the dallas cowboys so for me
he was
he was a coach of the month in uh in
helping pull off that comeback but the
falcons will have their hands full
believe me in uh in green bay the way
the way mr rogers has
started out the season so i i really
don't have a pick
in the nfc i listen to anybody and what
they think
but what i saw monday night andy reid
and the kansas city chiefs
are going to be very hard to deal with
come next several no doubt about it
because that kid is so damn special at
quarterback
and that playbook is so perfectly
uh scripted for him and then his way to
be
unscripted and the the talent around him
it is just a perfect setup and it is
ready to roll
that said in the in the in the nfc
you know maybe just maybe if the the
seahawks start tightening the bolts
defensively the way that russell wilson
is playing he's playing out of his mind
right now um and and i'm
i i don't know this could be seattle's
year out of the nfc too
brent if you think about it very good
point rich very very good point
let me go back in time with russell
wilson when he came to wisconsin
uh as his graduate year and i covered
the badgers for a good football team and
i covered several of his games
and we had several long meetings with
russell wilson
i loved his game and he remember he was
a baseball player and
north carolina state didn't want him to
to go to the colorado rockies a minor
league
program that one spring and they changed
quarterbacks and went to
uh somebody else and so he transferred
i have to tell you that he was one now
the most impressive
college quarterback in terms of the nfl
that i covered was peyton manning beyond
a shadow of a doubt stated senior year
was everything you'd want the second
would be andrew luck okay
i knew that he would be a successor but
i gotta tell you the third best college
quarterback that i was around
looking forward to the nfl was russell
wilson and i suspect because of his size
but when you have a quarterback and this
goes to mahomes also when you have a
quarterback who is also a good baseball
player all right not necessarily a
pitcher remember russell was playing
second base with rocky
you throw the ball at different angles
you come across
and when you look at the velocity of the
accuracy of his throws when he has to
drop them down
and the space that russell finds he and
the homes are outstanding
i've never seen but remember mahomes was
around baseball a lot because his dad he
was in major league baseball locker
rooms he would go out into the outfield
he would shag
flies as a little boy he was around that
game
now i did not cover patrick mahomes in
college i'm not sure that i did one
texas tech game
but i did a lot of wisconsin games and i
loved russell wilson he was accurate
down
field he knows as a little guy he knows
how to move for daylight he knows how to
find it
and he's a great runner he's very
courageous his father
a lot of people don't realize his father
went to the san diego chargers final cut
one year as a wide receiver
and was turned loose they offered him a
spot on the on the practice squad
and he said no i'm going to go home with
my family he then came back to the east
and he insisted that russell wilson go
to good private schools
russ got a great education uh talking to
him
i always i always enjoyed it very very
much but he is very smart
winning quarterbacks in the nfl judgment
judgment that's your first thing that
you've got to do okay
and it it speaks to both mahomes and i
again i don't know him
i was around his father actually a
couple of times uh kind of a middle
relief pitcher for a while when i was
around him but
but the intelligence that these
quarterbacks have to have
uh they have to make such split
decisions and they
and you must throw accurately the nfl
johnny already told me and i think i've
told you before
when i asked in the biggest steps in
college in the nfl he said the field is
so much smaller in the nfl
and that speaks to the kind of athletes
and the speed that that you're up
against but you're absolutely right i do
not want to overlook russell wilson but
but they must improve that defense going
forward before the playoffs
brent i could literally talk to you all
day i want to talk to you all day
i wish i could talk to you all day but
my gosh i just love our chats
i love when you come on this show i love
the fact that you say yes
i love the fact that i i uh i think of
you literally every time i take the
chair of nfl game day morning knowing
that if it wasn't for you
shows like that would not exist and um i
thank you for that i thank you for
everything i appreciate it in fact
you guys you guys do a great job over
there thank you yeah nfl network uh
you know listen i wake up i wake up to
you guys
uh i look forward to sunday morning i
always got my phone
ipad down there in the booth you know
living in my two billion dollar
stadium and watching the bridge eisen
and the guy okay
guys have a have a great weekend take
you take care of yourself brent be safe
we'll uh listen for your call raiders
and bills uh the vision managing editor
and
hall of famer brent mossberger here on
the rich eisens show